we've had a statement from the duke of
cambridge prince william
paying tribute to his grandfather the
duke of edinburgh in the statement
he said my grandfather's century of life
was defined by service to his country
and commonwealth to his wife and queen
and to our family
i feel lucky to have had not just had
his example to guide me
but his enduring presence well into my
own adult life both
through good times and the hardest days
i will always be grateful
that my wife had so many years to get to
know my grandfather
and for the kindness he showed her i
will never take for granted
the special memories my children will
always have of their great grandpa
coming to collect them in his carriage
and seeing for themselves his
infectious sense of adventure as well as
his mischievous
sense of humour my grandfather was an
extraordinary man
and part of an extraordinary generation
catherine and i will continue to do what
he would have wanted
and will support the queen in the years
ahead i miss my grandpa
but i know he would want us to get on
with the job
let's go to our royal correspondent
rhiannon mills who's in windsor for us
now
a deeply personal uh statement there
from
the duke of cambridge following the
death of his grandpa
it is and i think we anticipated that we
were likely to hear from the duke of
edinburgh's grandchildren
at some point today after all over the
weekend we heard from
his four children paying their own
tributes talking about that significant
loss
at the void in the queen's life that
there now is following the death of
prince philip
and now yes we are starting to hear the
tributes from his grandchildren
accompanying that statement there was
also released a photograph
showing at the duke of edinburgh and
sitting
on a carriage because we know he was
keen very keen on his carriage driving
he actually
drew up the international rule book for
carriage driving and sitting alongside
him
is a little prince george and so a very
touching photograph that prince william
and kate have decided to release
alongside that statement
but i think if we if we look at some of
the things that he had to say
reflecting on the fact that his
grandfather's century of life was
defined as he says
by service to the country the
commonwealth
to the queen and also our family talk
about how he feels lucky that he had his
example to guide him that his enduring
presence
well into his adult life both through
good times
and the hardest days and of course that
does make us think back to the fact that
it was
prince philip who encouraged prince
william to walk behind
princess diana's coffin during those
very difficult days
and back in 1997 when the country
mourned
the death of the princess of wales and
he also says i will never take for
granted the special memories that my
childhood will always have
my children sorry will always have of
their great grandpa coming to collect
them in his carriage and of course we
have seen
that photograph that he's been and
that's been released
but also i think it's it's really
wonderful to hear prince william there
talking
about the duke's infectious sense of
adventure
as well as his mischievous sense of
humor and i think what really stands out
to me is the final sentence
in that statement where he says i know
he would want us to get on
with the job and i think that's what
we're going to see from the royal family
this week
and certainly in the weeks ahead
following the funeral
on saturday i anticipate that yes they
will go into that they are now in this
two-week period of mourning but we have
been told that there will still be some
engagements where
it is deemed to be appropriate and also
for the royal family as well very
important to come out and pay their
thanks to all the members of public
who've been
paying their tributes and i think share
this moment
with the country and people around the
world